Cinded is a clothing brand that as you
know we're boycotting Israeli products.
Go to cindid.com. Why? I've been wearing
their products for years for six, seven,
eight years from training, gym, boxing,
jogging, praying all this is extra long
and sisters and even women's wear. I
urge you guys to check them out. They
got beautiful, beautiful clothing
amazing clothes from them in brothers
and sisters. You can see for yourself
with variety of amazing amazing clothing
brothers and sisters that suitable for
all ages and both genders in enjoy the
video.
>> You guys are you Christian, atheist,
agnostic? Uh, no. We're nonbelievers.
>> Uh, so you're atheist.
>> Yes, that's the word. I don't know the
word.
>> Yeah, atheist. Yes. I can I can prove
God exists. What even do you need to
believe in God or a creator?
>> I can prove God exists in two minutes.
>> Okay. I I believe there is a God.
>> Yes.
>> But I don't believe in like how they
play the beliefing out like the rules
they made and things. I don't like it.
So, so you you believe in a creator, but
you don't believe in the rules?
>> I like in some rules, but not all.
>> Okay. So, some rules, not all. You do
you believe in God or you don't believe?
>> Um, well, I'm like a little bit
spiritual. I believe in the universe and
uh like that kind of stuff, but I don't
believe like the universe is a person.
So, not a god, but I believe in the
universe.
>> Okay. So, we agree with that. So, we we
we agree that the universe is an
inanimate in that sense. Yeah. So, we
don't believe the universe is God.
>> So, let's just I can prove God exists in
2 minutes.
>> Yes. If you guys
>> Okay, I'll use your ring. Can I look at
your ring?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Do you accept Okay. Do you mind
taking off?
>> Yeah.
>> I'm not going to run away. Don't worry.
>> No.
>> So,
>> yeah. So, you you will accept, sister,
that there's a Vshape.
>> Yeah.
>> Is that what your name stands?
>> Is this the initial of your name?
>> No. Okay. Good. So you accept that it
has a specific pattern. It's
symmetrical.
>> Yeah.
>> Good. It has diamonds.
>> Yeah. No. Yeah.
>> Okay. Good. This this this Yeah. Okay.
But it's this has a purpose. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. I'll just give that to you. So
that ring has a specific shape. It has a
design and it has a purpose.
>> Yeah. I know this story and we are
designed to
>> Good. So good. So you would agree that
your eye is far more complex in design
than your ring, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Good. Your eye is million times more
complex cuz your eye is made out of DNA.
Yeah,
>> we do know DNA has information.
>> So it's composed of three billion
letters.
>> It's like letters. Yeah. Okay. Good. So
if there's information, it requires
intelligence.
>> So for example, if I have a book, if the
book has information, it means somebody
wrote that book.
>> Yeah.
>> There's intelligence. Yeah.
>> Do you understand what I mean?
>> Yeah.
>> Good. So we say if the ring has a
designer, the ring has a purpose. The
ring has a shape. You have a shape. You
have a purpose. You have to have a
designer. Something must have created
you.
>> Yeah. Yeah. That that sounds that sounds
reasonable. That sounds reasonable. I
think I think that's a really good like
uh thing. I think that's really smart.
But I don't like the I just don't like
the way they
>> Okay, let's Okay, we'll come to the
rules. Do we agree that rationally and
logically there has to be a a creator
that created us.
>> Um um no actually I'm not sure of that
because um I also believe in science. So
>> you look you can you know you know like
Darwin you know Darwin
>> Charles Darwin he was he was the one who
came with evolutionary theory but he
believed in God.
>> So so so you can be someone that
believes in science and believe in God.
>> I know but like I I'm raised to believe
in science because my dad also is like a
DNA scientist. Good.
>> So the way I'm brought up is like to
believe in science and that's why people
are things are the way they are.
>> But I believe in science now with
science. Science tells us how things
work. So science will come and tell us
the way the bees work like you know
bees.
>> Yeah. Okay. You know bees are very
intelligent. You know when a bee for
example goes and finds honey. Yes. Or or
nectar. Yes. It comes back to the
colony. So you know where the colony
where all the bees are. The bee comes
back and it starts to dance. You know
what that dance means? So it wiggles it
tail
>> in a specific shape. What it's doing is
it's telling the other bees where the
nectar is and the direction. So the bees
have a solar compass. Even when it's
cloudy, they know where the sun is. So
what it does is it intelligently knows
where the nectar is. It comes back and
tells the other bees the direction and
the distance of where the nectar is.
That's intelligence. So we say which
being created them to be cognitive and
have intelligence. It has to be a
creator. Does that make sense?
>> Okay.
>> So So what we're saying is that all of
this intelligence and the bees and the
creation and the sun and the moon, there
is order. If there is order, there has
to be an order maker. So we say that is
the creator.
>> Okay. So logically and rationally and
going with science. Science used as a
empiricism which is your eyes, sight,
hearing, touching, feeling. Yeah. So
these are the things that we use. So we
say we use these things logically and
rationally to understand there must be a
creator that created you the way you
are. Your DNA makes your hair blonde,
mine not, your eyes whatever color, mine
a different color. So we say it's done
purposefully.
>> Does that make sense?
>> Okay. And now
>> good. Now going back to the rules. So if
a creator exists, for example, are you
guys you're not married?
>> No, we're not. Okay. Once one day when
you get married and you have children,
would you agree if your child comes to
you and says, "I want to try cocaine."
Would you say, "Yeah, go and try some
cocaine." Or would you say, "No, that's
not good for you."
>> But for me, the rules is about gay
people. I don't
>> homosexuality.
>> Yes. I don't And I don't think it's like
good that other people.
>> Yeah. Sorry. You're famous.
>> I don't think
that other people get like get punished
because they are how they are.
So I I'll tell you I tell you as in
Islam. Look, we're not we're not
Christians. So Christians go and tell
gay people you're going hell. In Islam,
we are not allowed to tell anyone
they're going hell. As a Muslim, if you
are argument sake, a lesbian or gay, you
can still be a Muslim. We believe that
the sin is acting upon it. And even if
you act upon it, you can still be a
Muslim.
>> To to not be a Muslim is to deny that
God doesn't exist. So if you're gay or
lesbian or whatever, you can still be a
Muslim. Even if you are committing the
sin, you still can be a Muslim. The only
place you don't become a Muslim is as a
gay person. If you say, "God loves what
I do." Okay, God doesn't love what you
do. We're a sinner. For example, a man
who goes and sleeps around or a woman
who goes sleeps around in the sight of
God, you're still sinning. But it
doesn't mean it doesn't make you a
Muslim. So there's a misconception cuz a
lot of Christians, they say, "Oh, you're
going to hell."
Because the one who created us decides
for example you would agree argument
sake if I for example gave you 10
billion but tomorrow you're going to die
would you take the money?
>> No
>> good you which means life is more
precious than 10 billion
>> who is the one that's giving you that
life every day we say the one who
created you if the one who created you
has created you and given you everything
your mom your dad the food that you eat
it only requires that we have to be
obedient to his commands because we live
on his earth. If we live like you know
we live in under your mom's rule and you
say something she says listen you're in
my house you listen to my rules yeah
she's your mom you say okay mommy
because you know mom loves you mom
doesn't want bad for you so when mom
comes and says don't do drugs don't do
gambling don't drink alcohol it's
because she cares and loves you so we
believe God loves us and wants us to
stay away from certain things
>> I like I think it's the way um a lot of
people go about it when a lot of Muslims
don't be respected to u people who love
men or love women Yes.
>> So I just I don't I don't like the way I
like the belief and I like the the book
itself, but I don't like how people
>> True. But but Muslims, look, there are
good and bad Muslims. There's good and
bad Christians. There's good and bad
atheists. As Muslims, we are not allowed
to say to a gay person, you are going
hell. It's not permissible because God
decides who's going where. I might be a
Muslim. I might end up in the hellfire.
So we have to be humble. So I'm sorry
that you came across these Muslims who
are judgmental. I get that. I'm a
Muslim. I get hate from Muslims
sometimes. So, it's not correct for us
to treat people. I've spoken to many gay
people like in London. I can remember we
have our table like this in Leicester
Square in central London. I don't know.
Have you guys been London before?
>> Okay. If you go to London, there's you
know where the TV is
>> like the there's there's a big screen.
It's like um
>> it's called Pikatini Circus
>> in central London. Okay. So, we have a
table there. Once I was trying to speak
to a gay man. He's like, "No, no, you
guys don't like me." I said, "No, we
have Listen," I said, "Give me a
chance." I spoke to him. I said,
"Listen, we don't have anything against
you. We just say the act is a sin, but
you still can be a Muslim. He was
shocked. I said, "Really?" I said, "Yes,
really." I spoke to him. I gave him a
Quran. We had a nice conversation
together. He went his way because
there's a misconception that we think
gays are evil and we don't hate them.
The sin, yes, but the same applies to a
man who goes and sleeps around a woman.
The same applies to a woman who goes
sleeps around with men. The sin is a
sin. We don't hate the individual. Yes,
we do hate the sin, you know. So, in a
nutshell, like if you look into Islam,
forget what Muslims do. Yes, Muslims are
good and bad. You have all sorts. But if
you read the Quran for yourself, you
will accept and understand. If I was to
give you a mansion, cars, money, you
will be respectful towards me. If I call
you and say, "What's your name, sister?"
>> Uh, Hassa.
>> Hassa. If I say, "Hassa, listen. I need
help. Come and help." You say, "Okay,
Ali, no problem." Why? Because you're
like, "Ali's good. He looks after me."
Whatever. If he needs help one day, I
will pick up. So with God, God makes
your heart beat. Every day your heart
beats. Do you tell your heart to beat?
>> Do you control your heart to beat? Good.
So we we say God if he's created us he
looks after us. You eat food when you
eat food does it taste good?
>> Yes.
>> Who who c good? Who created your who
created your taste bud? Who created your
eye? Who created your nose? Who created
your like your whole system? So we say
if God has done that for us it only is
fair that we are obedient to what he
says. That's our position.
>> Okay. But like the beast cannot pray but
they still have been created to God. Are
they going to hell?
>> No. No. We don't we don't believe. So we
believe judgment is for cognitive beings
like me and you, we know right from
wrong. So when when God tells us do A
and do B. However, in Islam, we believe
if you didn't hear the message of Islam,
you will not go hell because God is
just. How could why would God throw you
in hell if you stand and say, "God, I
one day spoke to Ali, my name's Ali. He
told me something about Islam, but I
wasn't convinced." You have a case in
front of God cuz we only believe you
will get the punishment if I prove to
you Islam is the truth and in your heart
you say I think Islam is the truth and
you say but I don't want to follow it
cuz I want to follow my desires then
you're in trouble but till now you don't
know about Islam you're still searching.
Yeah. So if you die in the state you
will be in front of God and God will
judge you fairly. We don't believe in a
God that's a vampire and he wants to
throw everyone in hellfire. rather the
God we believe if you read the Quran
every chapter starts with Allah the most
merciful the very merciful so God is
mercy like he is the most merciful and
he doesn't want hellfire for his
servants he says in the Quran Allah says
what would I get out of throwing you in
hellfire what what benefit is it for me
to throw you in hellfire which means
what god wants paradise for you yes and
if you think about it sister in this
earth like we have food we enjoy we
obviously if you're married you have
intimacy that's something that you enjoy
when you sleep it's you enjoy. So, if
God can create us and give us all of
these things that we can enjoy, is it
impossible for him to give us an eternal
life where we're going to get everything
and more and there's going to be no pain
and no uh sorrow?
>> It's a possibility.
>> Yeah. Sorry, I talked too much. But
>> it's okay. It's okay. Minutes.
>> No, the two minutes was for the gods.
>> Okay. Okay. I'm going to think about
this at home.
>> Okay. Do you have Quran? Can I give you
Quran?
>> Uh
>> for free.
>> No, thank you. I'm fine.
>> Okay. You can give it to me because you
did you tried so hard.
>> I tried my best. Okay, thank you. Are
you sure?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, no problem. But if you Okay. Do
you want it in Dutch or English?
>> Dutch.
>> Okay.
>> I have here for him.
>> Okay, perfect. He's too He's faster than
me.
>> You can put it It might fit in your bag
maybe.
>> Yes, it fit in my bag maybe.
>> Thank you. to sleep.